or police in the UK have arrested an
Egyptian citizen accused of smuggling
thousands of people across the
Mediterranean he's also linked to the
migrant boat which capsized and sank off
the coast of Greece last week which
killed 82 people were Flags above
Pakistan's Parliament House are at
half-mast in honor of the more than 200
victims who were from Pakistan police
have also arrested 29 people they say
were human Smugglers connected to the
case
which on siropolis joins us live now
from malacasa and can you just bring us
up to date with where things are at with
the investigation
well at the moment there is an there is
a judicial process to prosecute nine
Egyptian Nationals who are believed to
be among the Smugglers those people were
among the 104 survivors of the June 14th
wreck there's a separate judicial
investigation at the Supreme Court level
into the circumstances under which the
ship capsized and whether there's only
complicity by the Greek Coast Guard in
that so neither of these processes have
yet produced any publicly announced
results but we expect to hear from from
them in due course Tom and John you've
been speaking with some of the survivors
what have they been telling you
well some of the testimony we've heard
the eyewitness testimony from people
we've been talking to today
confirms that tragically there were many
minors in the hold of the ship one of
the people we spoke to talked about a
hundred young people
mostly teenagers and mostly from Syria
boys and girls
somebody else we spoke to talked about
even younger children three four five
years old
and apparently there were six Syrian
mothers accompanying some of those
children others were traveling with
cousins uncles and fathers
as you know only men survived this wreck
presumably because the women and
children were as has now been confirmed
to us below decks some people say that
they were at the bottom of the ship in
the hold others told us that they were
on the second level immediately below
the top deck they may have been divided
into two groups but the question of
whether the Coast Guard played a role in
the sinking of this trawler Still
Remains somewhat blurry because one of
the people we spoke to believes that
there was no tow rope attached to the
trawler before it capsized that it did
so because its engine had failed and the
lack of Forward Motion uh caused the
ship to sway from side to side much more
violently than it had been but that it
had been doing so throughout the five
day Voyage simply because it was
overloaded it seems that the engine
failure was the final blow and that that
side to side motion simply became too
great and the weight weight of people
shifted inside the ship once the uh that
motion had become too great
another witness however who survives
this wreck told us that there had been a
tow rope attached that the Greek Coast
Guard offered it in order to help these
people reach Shore and then cut it off
before reaching the shore because the
Coast Guard was apparently afraid that
the toe was causing the ship to sway
side to side so violently but after that
rope was cut off it swayed even more so
we have conflicting testimonies in this
and this is going to be I think the
central topic of the Supreme Court
investigation into the Greek Coast Guard
okay thank you so much uh heartbreaking
stories uh coming there thank thank you
that's John ceropoulos uh live for us in
malacasa